so what works and I would argue I ignore
our digital banner pre will have I think
those are I totally agree I love you for
that and I would have gotten into that
without you like I actually I think
banner ads are more [ __ ] than radio
right because I don't think it's who
hears click the banner ad this year
exactly right so here's what I hear
here's what I do know I do know through
data through direct response and looking
at the math that Facebook dark posts
work right but because it's native and
it's in feed and you're seeing it now I
also know through data and behavior and
all the like testing that I'm doing that
it's working less today than it did
seven months ago for many reasons one as
soon as the media started picking up on
it you started paying attention a little
more that the little beige sponsored
post was like yeah why am I seeing that
in a world where you were used to seeing
[ __ ] that you can follow because friends
shared it and the context was created
so look what works Instagram you know
why cuz it's by hand it's not
programmatic you have to do it in a
certain way but it's not being done by a
lot of people yet so it still catches
your attention it's that same old game
so look at pre-roll for YouTube
everybody knows if you look at any
behavior under 25 year old 25 and under
will open up multiple tabs on YouTube
wait for the pre-roll to go and then go
back into your tabs and watch the videos
that's about as shitty as a TV
commercial right here's the difference
David a CPM a TV commercial is a
shitload more right so like if you're
gonna throw money directly in the trash
I'd rather you throw in less you know
it's it's kind of one of those things so
look everything I believe in dies
usually thirty six months later right
I built my wine business that Arnie
mentioned on on Google AdWords and email
marketing I email open rates that were
ninety percent in nineteen ninety six
ninety you know why nobody was marketing
that way and back in the day and you're
all too young back in the day when email
really first hit the scene you read
every [ __ ] word of every email this
is new and like it was good it was like
better than a mail like you know like it
was just
you just liked it and most of all and
here's the reason spam hadn't started
yet
right so you know it's like why all of
you love texting right now and me too
because for the most part outside of a
couple things that have figured out how
to penetrate you're not getting spam in
your texts and that's why you're paying
attention right
so did what's working Facebook dark
posts are working right now Pinterest is
really working like really really
working it's a little expensive but the
ad products coming down that will be a
big win for a lot of people but I'm with
you I think banner is as bad as it gets